I would like first to thank all our
health workers doctors and researchers
who are working I want the clock to save
lives I would also like to offer wealth
of support to those who are ill and are
fighting the virus as we speak this
pandemic is putting our societies and
the sheer strain the well-being of each
EU member-states
depends on the well-being of the whole
of the EU we are all in this together
fighting
Korona and instantly trenches will take
time but we have already made a lot of
progress and taken bold action members
of the European Council to the health
the force video conference to deal with
the travis 19 and eastern frequencies we
have expressed a strong will to move
forward together we discussed progress
on the various dimensions of the
European respond to the pandemic and
welcomed the joint European world map
towards lifting of 1219 containment
measures we all agreed that the health
and safety of our citizens comes first
we also agree to continue to follow the
situation closely in particular as we
approach the holiday season and to
coordinate as much as possible to ensure
the gradual and elderly lifting the
restrictions we will count the joint
roadmap for recovery it sets out some
important principles such as solidarity
cohesion
transversions it further defines four
key areas for action a fully functioning
civil market an unprecedented investment
effort acting globally and a functioning
system of governance it's of all most
important to increase strategic autonomy
of the Union and produce essential
essential roots in Europe following the
meeting of the Eurogroup in an
impressive format who endorsed the
agreement on three important safety nets
for workers businesses and sovereigns
amounting to a package worth five
hundred forty billion euros we told for
the package to be operational by 1st of
June 2020 we also agreed to work towards
establishing a recovery fund which is
needed and urgent this fund shall be of
a sufficient magnitude targeted toward
the sectors and geographical parts of
Europe most affected and be dedicated to
dealing with this unprecedented crisis
we have therefore asked the Commission
to analyse the exact needs and to
urgently come up with a proposal that's
commensurate with the challenge we are
facing the Commission proposal should
clarify the link with the MFF which is
any event will need to be adjusted to
deal with the current crisis and it's
aftermath the Eurogroup in an intensive
format will continue to closely monitor
the economic situation and prepare the
ground for a robust recovery we remain
committed to give in to the necessary
impetus to work on the week of refund as
well as the MFF
so that a balanced agreement on both can
be found as soon as possible we
discussed also the situation without in
the drilling activities and I would like
to add that the illegal drilling
activities by Turkey
in Cyprus exclusive economic zone were
raised by some Member States we
expressed our full celerity with Cyprus
and we told and we affirmed our previous
expressed conclusions on this matter
we agreed also that we will have a video
conference the 6th of May with the
Western Balkan countries you know that
the last months worth worth in order to
adapt our strategy to take decisions
regarding this region with the support
of the Commission and the 6th of May
will be do children to have
videoconference with those countries in
order to express what are our priorities
also for this region I thank you thank
you very much
Charla can seamlessly follow up on your
words the health situation is by far not
following fully under control and many
member states have not yet reached the
peak but at the same time you already
know that the scale the speed and the
impact of the economic crisis is
unprecedented in modern times while the
pandemic knows certainly no borders and
is blind to nationalities some countries
are certainly hit harder than others and
alas unless we act decisively and
collectively the recovery will not be
symmetric and divergences between member
states will increase
I'm therefore very happy that the
leaders is even in task the Commission
was shaping our collective response to
the crisis we will indeed carry out a
thorough assessment of the impact of the
crisis on the overall European economy
on our member states but certainly also
on some specific sectors we know
definitely that the GDP will fall
everywhere but it will fall more sharply
in some member states than in others and
there will be more damaged certainly to
certain sectors like for example tourism
than to others we know also that the
fiscal impact of the crisis differs
significantly as some member states are
able to provide much more direct
budgetary support to their economies
than others we have discussed one
example that is for example state aid up
to today's state aid sums up to almost
1.8 trillion euros but there are huge
differences in how much state aid our
member states are giving and this is
also linked to the financial space they
have this difference will have massive
effects on the level playing field
unless we counter balance that we have
to design a common future proof answer
to this to ensure the integrity and the
cohesion of the single market and its
shared prosperity the response that we
will have to give must be first repair
crisis damage and then generate recovery
build resilience and guide our economies
along the path of the green and the
digital transitions in a fair manner I
am convinced it is that there is only
one instrument that can deliver this
magnitude of tasks behind the recovery
and that is the European budget clearly
linked to the recovery fund the budget
is time-tested everybody knows it
it is trusted by all Member States and
it is per se designed for investment for
cohesion and convergence and therefore I
am glad that the member states showed
unity impressive encouragement for the
Commission to explore innovative
financial instruments in relation to the
MFF the next mff the next seven year n
FF budget has to adapt to the new
circumstances post corona crisis we need
to increase its firepower to be able to
generate the necessary investment across
the whole European Union and therefore
we will propose to increase the
so-called Headroom that is to say
the space between the existing ceiling
in the MFF and the own resources ceiling
thanks to the legal guarantee by member
states the Commission will be able to
raise funds which will then be channeled
through the European budget into the
Member States our current estimates of
the needs lead us to think that an own
resources ceiling up around 2% of gni
for two or three years instead of the
current 1.2 percent will be required the
money raised as I said will be
channelled back into the MFF through a
recovery program and concentrated and
into a number of programs that will help
tackle this crisis and let me name four
areas I'm speaking of increased
financial support for investment and
reforms in member states and cohesion
that's where the bulk of the investment
will go to more investment of course in
our modern policies this is the European
Green Deal and digital transition and
increased strategic autonomy a smaller
part will go into improving the
resilience of our common crisis response
tools that is the lessons learned in
this crisis and of course there has to
be a pillar which is strengthening our
support to our neighborhood and partners
the investment should be front loaded in
the first years and of course it is
necessary to find the right balance
between grants and loans this whole
endeavor is about protecting the
integrity of our single market and of
our Union and if we do it well and
succeed then the investments will have
been worth every single cent we pay for
them now thank you thank you to both
presidents for their introduction I see
a lot of you have already raised their
blue hand I'm going to take a couple of
questions please state your name and
your news outlet we're going to start
with mark paper cotton please mark
Stachel
we have a guideline mark could you speak
up a bit absolutely it is better can you
hear me yes okay I have a question for
both presidents the person's permission
denied
when you talk about increasing the
ceiling from one point percent to two
percent how much money could be raised
and the second question is for President
Michelle so of course this has to be
looked at thoroughly and is dependent of
the overall result we will have but we
are talking we are not talking about
billion we are talking about trillion No
thank you I really the positive
assessment about this meeting tonight it
was a really promising European Council
why because we agreed on a very clear
framework we are convinced that because
this crisis is very huge it's very
important to terrorists own decisions
and we have considered it was important
at the same time to work on the next mff
for the next seven years and to use this
very stone tool which is also a tool for
solidarity in Europe but at the same
time we have decided to work on the
recovery front and it means that indeed
about the modalities it will be very
important to 20 new our efforts and
centrally based on the concrete
proposals made by the Commission it will
be possible with all the Member States
to try to have a common approach and to
take decisions together but I'm really
optimistic because even if it's
difficult even if of course there are
different sensitivities in Europe and
confidence to the surprise
I feel there is a very strong political
will toward together and to succeed to
build compromises
thank you very much passing on the line
now - excuse me
so Beatriz Rios please Beatriz could you
state your news outlet and put your
question forward thank you yes I will
Fred you're active and my question is
when it comes to the differences between
the member states regarding loans and
grants where do we spend
how many member states are more willing
to use grants instead of laws and how
many are they will need to use loans and
then regarding the Long's
if we're not talking about prepared all
that what kind of maturity that we
expect of long-term thank you okay
so as you can imagine there is a variety
of opinions about grants and loans and
what kind of proportion that they should
have so there will certainly be a sound
balance between grants and loans and
this is method of - negotiation within
the group with the Member States so that
we find a good mixture of loans and
grants there are pros and cons for both
you know the arguments so these
arguments have been exchanged tonight
but in a very constructive manner I can
only underline what the president of the
council has said and the same goes for
the maturity of the loans of potential
loans so this all has to be negotiated
in detail now and has to be discussed
for us was important that we are clear
about the frame and that we get a strong
backing that we will work on this frame
and fill it with life in close
cooperation with the member states and I
would like to add that the failure -
tonight we have already discussed the
which part for loans which part for
grants and it shows that we are already
stressing the first questions about the
modalities and it demonstrates that
there is this very strong political will
two like together in order to have an
agreement on animal faith and on which
every friend we know that it would be
difficult because these are difficult
top is difficult questions but I repeat
that we felt that the debate was very
rational which is a very good and we
felt also that the rest is very strong
political will to try to work together
and to take decisions together in the
nest which yes we're going to take the
next question from David Coretta Roger
your Adhikari have it are you there yes
thank you David keator idiotic Allen I
have a question for president Michelle
the Italian Prime Minister during the
debate said that there is political
emergency or urgency right now do you
see a political risk in this moment in
the European Union and in particular in
in Italy and a second question for
president underlying
[Music]
recovery fund will not start before I
guess 2021 do you foresee a bridge
solution to to allow member states to
use that money before the next year
thank you it's it's totally right that
there is a real sense of urgency and
it's important to to our very heart and
to take decisions and if you look the
last weeks we have in four or five weeks
we have eight for video conference at
the level of the head of state and the
head of the violence it shows that
politically we are totally aware that
it's important to work together and to
take our own decisions and if you look
also in comparison with the past at the
European level the financial crisis for
example a few years ago we can see that
only in a few weeks we took very stern
and impressive decisions
uf so what has been decided by the
Eurogroup we have asked the Eurogroup to
implement by the 1st of June the
concrete decisions that we have already
taken and very important for the workers
it's also important for the businesses
it's also important not to support the
different member says but it's not
enough and because it's not enough we
effort we depend on the Commission in
order to propose to the head of state
and head of government of framework a
very concrete framework sheet which is a
road map in order to whoever current
approach in to tailor his own decisions
and I repeat that the fact that we have
already discussed at the level of the
head of states distraction of possible
balance between grants loans and our
different opinions on that it
demonstrates that we are committed in
order to take decisions as soon as
possible even if we are not naive we
know that it will be necessary to
continue all our our paternal efforts
and with the other situation different
member states also in Italy I think it
will be important to demonstrate from
the European perspective that this
Europe that this European project is
very strong and that our command role
it's more convergence more hydrogen and
more solidarity and we will act in order
to make this demonstration so addressing
your question on the recovery program
and from 21 on together which is topping
the MFF and the question of a bridging
solution indeed a few member states
asked for some thoughts about a bridging
solution and the Commission is willing
to look into that we have been asked for
it and there are some ideas that might
fit for us it's important that we should
recall that right now if you take all
the measures of Member States and the
European institutions
three point three trillion have been put
out now to stabilize our European
economy so we have time right now to
work intensively on a new proposal for
an new European budget topped by a
recovery program
but of course we are willing to look
into bridging solutions thank you
present on the line next question goes
to Maria Sara Maria are you there yes
you are yes hear me yes please put your
question sorry I was curious first of
all because you asked Peron
and first of all I didn't get it exactly
which is a time line in front of us is
there any deadline do have time later or
something like that and secondly or
president Otto von der Leyen it said
that the Commission will work lively and
closely with the states if you could
elaborate a little more of the way that
the Commission will work to bring this
proposal again to their leaders thank
you
the first question what's wrong there is
there is a fire repeat that there is a
real sense of urgency and that's why our
intention is to to make some concrete
proposals in the European continent for
that we've asked the Commission to make
some some concrete proposals regarding
the MFF recovery fund and the link
between both instruments and I
understand that it's the International
Commission to propose a we quickly some
concrete modalities and based on that we
will appreciate when it will it will be
possible again to have a meeting at the
level of the leaders yes and regarding
your question how to work together with
the Member States this is a normal
process so before this council of course
we have been in close contact and
dialogue with all the Member States and
the president of the council and we are
elaborating about ideas and possibility
so therefore and only therefore it was
possible today to have this strong
support of the framework of the idea the
plan to move forward and this is exactly
the same way we will be moving forward
in the next days so in close cooperation
and dialogue with the Member States to
understand where their leeway and the
limits are what the different situation
in this different member states are
sometimes it's a different legal
situation that is in different member
states so take all this an account the
positive part today in our council was
that there was general openness to the
fact that indeed we have to find a
balance between grants and loans but
that it is a good idea to have the
recovery program and the new mff as one
package and to work on that and this
constructive approach was encouraging
Thank You Maria we're going for two more
questions
Tobias Keizer are you there d welt
yes I'm there thank you very much thank
you for giving us the opportunity um two
questions one to missus of on the line
could you give us a bit more of a
detailed timeframe what are you looking
at as far as the next steps are
concerned in this process particularly
your idea when we have a concrete
proposal for a recovery fund and the
other question to Masumi share do you
think the council will agree on a
recovery fund and an MMS
at all doing a videoconference or do you
think it will it will really encounter a
real person a real life to agree on
these issues thank you very much so yeah
what the time frame is concerned of
course we work as fast as possible and
the goal is because the the MFF the new
mff has to be a collegial process the
goal is to be in college either in the
second or in the third week of May
depending on the progress we have but as
I said in close dialogue with the member
states so that we have a very inclusive
process to move forward as you as you
know we don't need to we don't know when
it will be possible again to ask meeting
in person at the level of the European
Council and that's why we we are using
the new technologies in order to make
progress and we will see when it will be
possible to have a dent physical
meetings and and based on that will
appreciate well which outcome is
realistic without a physical meeting and
in case of necessity we will appreciate
which kind of decisions we take on that
I'm going to take one more question from
Sam Fleming from the Financial Times
Sam there you are taking the questions
question on the own resources ceiling on
the line could you give us a sense in
terms of the increased 2%
and how much extra debt issuance does
that allow for the Commission long the
overall size of BM the Recovery Fund and
we've seen figures around 300 billion
over two or three years does that sound
about right
based on the 2% figure and the question
for for president Michele obviously you
proposed compromise back in February of
around in terms of the size the MFF
around one point zero six to one point
zero seven percent of gni do you see any
convergence now given the urgency of the
crisis here and towards the compromise
level around there or do you think the
divisions are just as wired as ever when
it comes to the size of the answer thank
you so I hope you understand that I will
not elaborate about concrete figures
tonight but the process I was just
explaining it so that we have to show
and want to show respect to the Member
States so that we talk first of all with
them about what the balance could be as
you rightly pointed out the the own
resources ceiling is that is at a
certain proposed level we were talking
about about around two percent but of
course the question is how big is the
MFF that is part of the overall picture
- so this has to be discussed this there
are a lot of topics stemming from this
relation mff to own resources ceiling
also towards the question brands versus
loans and this has to be discussed and
today is too early to go in details in
that now we understand that the GDP will
be affected by the 2020s of this crisis
and about the numbers it will it will be
essential to continue our popular
dialogue in order to try to which some
some compromises also about the numbers
thank you to you all for your questions
and thank you for participating and
joining up and
you next time around for the next video
conference thank you
[Music]
you